can wikipedia help offline reinforcement
learning this is the title of the paper
that we're going to look at today this
paper is borderline preposterous in the
results that it presents language model
pre-training helps reinforcement
learning which is crazy the two domains
have almost nothing in common with each
other and yet there seems to be some
transfer from language to reinforcement
learning and this is not just about
pre-training on any old task the authors
here have tried various things and there
seems to be something special about
language so here's how the video looks
this video right here is a paper review
it presents me going through the paper
together with you explaining the paper
explaining what i think about the paper
what kind of questions i have and so on
after this video you'll have a good
understanding of what the paper contains
what its main claims are maybe also what
i think its weaknesses are in the next
video which will be released tomorrow i
will interview the authors of this paper
which is very cool the authors will have
seen my review and are directly able to
respond to criticisms to any questions
that are raised there and this is so
valuable we're able to directly dive in
and get you the best possible insight
into the behind the scenes stuff and
into the research process about this
paper i invite you to watch both videos
although feel free to choose whichever
one you like most as always let me know
what you think in the comments leave a
like if you do and i'll see you around
bye
[Music]
hello there today we're going to look at
can wikipedia help offline reinforcement
learning by michelle reed utaro yamada
and shishiang shenggu
this paper is a special paper because it
very counter counter-intuitively trains
a language model so it pre-trains a
transformer to do language modeling for
example wikipedia text modeling
as you can see right here language goes
in it does next word prediction like
you're used to from a language model
like gpt2 gpt3 and so on and then it
takes that transformer and fine-tunes it
to trajectory modeling this is a special
subfield of offline reinforcement
learning where decision transformers
have recently been introduced so in
offline reinforcement learning you have
some data set of trajectories and then
you try to do reinforcement learning
just given on that data set it turns out
that if you pre-train something on
language and then fine-tune it on these
trajectories that will turn out to be a
much better model like a much more
performant model for getting you good
reward at the end then if you just train
this uh
this trajectory model here from scratch
which is very counterintuitive because
it means that uh
somehow the language modeling task like
the language model pre-training has a
beneficial effect on the reinforcement
learning tasks that comes later
to note that the reinforcement learning
task has nothing to do with language and
even more special they also try a bunch
of other things most notably they try to
pre-train the image gpt model and that
does not result in good performance so
it's not just the fact that you have
pre-trained on something and it is
really very special result so we're
going to dive into the paper right here
the setup is fairly simple and then
there is a series of experiments that uh
try to investigate
this phenomenon
so
they say that
the offline reinforcement learning as i
said has been seen as a sequenced
sequence model and i've already
pre-annotated some stuff right here let
me know how you like that i i thought
i'd do it in this way so i have the
green that is the current one and the
yellow is from the previous my previous
escapades on this paper
so they go into offline reinforcement
learning and
that is being framed as simply
supervised learning to fit return
augmented trajectories in an offline
data set what do they mean they mean the
setup of the decision transformer i've
made a video on the decision transformer
if you want to look at that you can go
after you watch this video
but
so the decision transformer
has says well
see you are an agent somehow there is an
environment there is some interaction
between the agent and the environment
and in offline reinforcement learning we
usually have a data set of this so
someone else has performed this and they
have distilled all the episodes into
this into this data set and their goal
is to learn just from the data set we
can't actually interact with the
environment so in the data set there are
a number of trajectories trajectories of
the agent interacting with the
environment there's always some sort of
a state coming back from the environment
or an observation if you will
the agent always gives some sort of an
action back and then there is a reward
and then next state coming from the
environment and so on so that is
naturally a sequence and the sequence is
there is a state then there is an action
then there is a reward and a new state
then there is an action again and then
there is a reward and a new state so
this is a sequence and since i have a
data set of these sequences i might as
well throw that into a big transformer
to do sequence modeling now this has its
own problems which i've all discussed in
the decision transformer video for
example if the transformer has a context
length of four it cannot conceivably
like look back further than that um
which is a it's a classic problem in
reinforcement learning how to look back
and forward infinite times the
decision transformer has the limited
context window it has sort of the
caveats of language modeling however it
uh we understand language modeling very
well and therefore
we are quite able to do that there is
one modification that they do
what they do is they transform the
rewards right here they don't let the
model model the rewards they let it
model the rewards to go we're going to
see that in just a bit
this here is interesting what they say
is that
we look at whether transformer-based
pre-trained language models are able to
be adapted to standard offline
reinforcement learning tasks that have
no relations to language and i've
already told you that this is going to
work out fairly well
and that's the special message of this
paper
yeah so they show consistent performance
gains and significantly faster
convergence uh by faster convergence
they mean that a a convergence point
like a non-improving the loss anymore is
reached after much many fewer steps than
if you were to train from scratch which
makes sense for pre-training if it's in
the same domain but given that the
pre-training is a completely different
domain than the tuning that is still a a
you know just a special thing
so here is how we're going to frame the
problem and if you've watched the
decision transformer video this should
be familiar to you we model a episode as
a sequence in the following manner this
is almost as we've seen it except the re
rewards right here they are not
individual rewards but they are this
thing right here the sum of all the
rewards at
this and the next steps which they call
the returns to go
so this for example says from here until
the end of the episode i'm going to
gather 50 reward now maybe you're in
this state and you made an action that
gave you a reward of one so then this
here would be 49. so you'd say well from
here on out i'm going to make 49
reward
and so on so uh the benefit of this is
that at inference time you can just put
like a really high reward right here so
at inference time you would always you
would model these things you would get
from the environment so you'd start out
with like just a big reward right here
just
whatever the maximum you've observed
plus 10 or something to just encourage
your model to go uh very high
and you plug the state in here that the
environment has given you and you let
the model produce this one so it's
important that at training time we do
sequence modeling we really model the
sequence of
returns and state and action as a
gpt like next token prediction however
at inference time we obviously only
predict the action and the environment
is going to give us these two things
or the the environment is going to give
us the reward and then we simply
subtract the reward from the previous
returns to go and we plug that in here
and then we plug in the state we got
from the environment we let the model
predict the next action right here and
so on so this is this is very cool
because
much like a something like upside down
reinforcement learning this is
conditioned on a like a desired reward
this also has advantages and
disadvantages but the advantage is we
can control the reward we want at
inference time so we don't always have
to go for a high super high reward but
we can
um yeah so this is the
the setup you don't actually need to
understand much more
but you know
what we're going to do is we're going to
model this as a sequence in our data set
and then at inference time we just put
like some high returns to go and that's
it we're going to use a transformer for
that for the sequence model
and um
they're going to use a bunch of
different models right here for example
gpt2 small
which is a pre-trained model they also
pre-train their own that they call
chibi-t
which is the same size so that is the
same parameter count as the original
decision transformer uh to make it
comparable to them so the decision
transformer is the one that introduced
this
transformer as sequence model
for reinforcement learning and they're
going to see this gbt model has the
exact same amount of parameters as the
decision transformer so they can
directly compare what the language
pre-training is going to gain them in
the same model they also use clip
however they only as far as i am aware
they only use the text encoder part of
clip
because that's an auto regressive model
which can do the sequence modeling
and they use image gpt which is an auto
regressive model that goes via image
tokens so an image gpt it would split up
the image into pic no not pixels but
chunks i believe other chunks are pixels
i don't even remember and i would do a
sequence model essentially go through
the image like this
and then like this and then like this so
so it framed the image as a sequence of
either patches or pixels and go through
it
as as a sequence model so that's a
sequence model too we can pre-train it
and
then we can apply it to this to this
space
they do various things right here other
than just language modeling
sorry other than just
language or sequence prediction let's
call that sequence prediction right here
other than just sequence prediction for
the reinforcement learning data they do
two more things first of all they
want to align the input representations
so they have a set of language
embeddings which comes from the
pre-training data set now obviously the
pre-training data set has a tokenizer
that tokenizer generates tokens from the
text and every one of these tokens will
have one of these embeddings associated
with it so v is the vocabulary size
however obviously in the reinforcement
learning settings there we don't have
the same tokens we don't um have the
same input modality even and therefore
we need a new we don't need a tokenizer
because it's already tokenized right
each of these things right here is a
token
um
however what we do need is now a new
vocabulary
not a new vocabulary but a new embedding
matrix so to say so we have a different
amount of tokens so from one the the
three n tokens
and
uh
what we're going what we're going to
want to do
is what they say at least we want to
have a set of
a set of uh linear projections
uh that will map the
return embeddings the action embeddings
and the state embeddings uh to be very
close in their cosine similarity to some
to some embedding vector in the original
setting so that means they want to
force not force they want to encourage
the model to sort of reuse the
embeddings that it used during the
language model training
so for each of the input embeddings
they're going to find the maximum
close the closest nearest neighbor in
cosine space of the embeddings of the
original vocabulary and then they're
going to encourage the input embedding
the new input embedding to be closer to
uh to that
so that is just a loss that they add
during training
so you can see right here this is the
loss for the language or the sequence
modeling decision transformer objective
this is the loss that encourages the
embeddings to be close to the original
language embeddings or to one of the
original language embeddings and this
loss right here is um
the
continuation
of language modeling so during training
of the sequence prediction for
reinforcement learning they additionally
also do that's what they call language
model code training
continuing to train jointly on language
modeling and trajectory modeling
this allows us to to encourage
this allows us to encouraging
this probably should be encouraged
the models transformer backbone to be
able to handle both language and
trajectory simultaneously
okay maybe it helps
this seems
seems either like an idea that had been
had at some point or something they had
to put in after the fact
just to make it even a bit better
or because maybe it didn't work though
they ablated at some point and it also
works without
so that's almost it
um
yeah they they describe a little bit
their baselines and their setup i was a
bit confused here it says it's a batch
size of 65 000 tokens
which
i don't like i don't
is that
i don't batch size is usually not in
tokens
like the
sequence length would be in tokens but
in any case they say for our additional
objectives we
decay lambda 1 and lambda 2 to reach 0
after 5000 steps we tune the initial
values
f of lambda one and lambda two
and
you know these seem they seem reasonable
but the fact that you have to like decay
the additional losses after x many steps
and so on it points to a little bit of
brittleness in them and i'm not sure
always how brittle these things are
because reinforcement learning is
traditionally kind of
a very brittle field
so the main the main results
we have right here the top one is four
games in atari
the bottom one is i believe three
environments in the
in the open ai gym that are
oh sorry the
this is a data set the d4 rl data set
all of this is offline reinforcement
learning
on top you also have the one percent dqn
replay atari dataset
so as you can see
in many cases the
both the gbt and the gpd2 by the way
gpt2 is a lot larger than so this is a
lot larger in parameters than the gbt
model and therefore also
than the decision transformer model um
so just
just saying that so here the pre-trained
models outperform the other ones in
quite a few tasks however there is also
cubert
where they still do outperform the
decision transformer as you can see
but the their one of the baselines is
just a lot stronger the other baselines
are just useless that's kind of what i
mean when i complain about
um
when i complain about reinforcement
learning is that
it is just weird like a bit of a
different environment uh can make a
large difference
but as you can see the
pre language pre-trained models
consistently outperform the decision
transformer models
also something to note right here this
is mean and variance across three seeds
so this is variance i'm going to guess
they mean standard deviation
and
that is like a large number so if that's
the standard deviation then the the
differences to the decision transformer
they are well
well within that
and
that means well i mean it is visible
that across experiments we see the same
trend right that gives it credence but
also this just seems extremely noisy
and
yeah i'm i'm not gonna i'm not gonna say
i'm gonna sound like reviewer too when i
say well you should make more
experiments to
estimate or to get smaller error bars
but
it just seems like
i don't know it seems like results that
you can't
really
you know put
put a lot of weight on because
they're very noisy however um
a bit like a little bit less noisy or
the experiments here on the on the
bottom
you can see that the
standard deviations here are quite a bit
smaller
than on top
that's also three seeds uh i like i like
how they wrote the number three here and
the word three right here
that is just something that you never
see until someone points it out
um you can also see right here that uh
the decision transformer for example is
rather consistently outperformed what's
also interesting is that image gpt just
sucks like you can see right here like
it just it just it doesn't get anywhere
on any of these tasks also clip
very often underperforms you can see for
example here
um clip underperforms and they do have
some hypotheses on that that being said
there are still a lot of times where the
baselines here are quite a bit better or
just better than all of these
transformer-based models so just
pointing that out
yeah
they do also analyze and this i find
really interesting uh the attention
pattern between
the gpt-2 pre-trained model the image
gpt pre-trained model and what i
understand is a randomly initialized
model that has just been fine-tuned um
yeah randomly initialized model that has
just been fine-tuned
so
there's no pre-training so all of these
models are fine-tuned but the random one
hasn't been pre-trained interestingly if
you look at gpt-2 you can see these
bands right here and the bands are
always in the distance of three so
there's always three distance now three
should be an interesting number if you
remember the sequence how the sequence
is made
right here so there is always going to
be
one two three these these tokens come in
packets of three right their next return
would be here the next state would be
here the next action would be here so
every
every token in this attention pattern is
most focused on multiples of three
behind it in order to
um in order to predict the next token or
so there's always a lag of like or a
attention to multiples of three which
means that essentially you know if i
want to predict the next return probably
the last returns are the most important
if i want to predict the next action
maybe the last actions are
important this might also be a property
of the environment this is on on hopper
so on these continuous control tasks i
guess it's very often the case that i'm
just going to
repeat an action for a while if i want
to achieve some goal
i don't know the frame rate exactly of
these things however that seems to be
something that that is rather
maybe
viable to do and therefore looking at
the last action can give me a lot of
clues about the next action looking at
the last state can give me a lot of
clues about the next state i would
wonder how this changes if it's
something like
well i don't even know anywhere where i
don't like naturally repeat my last
action often
you can see this is the early layer then
in the middle layer the gpt2 it seems to
to sort of focus on on particular states
that seem to be important
as you can see right here so this is
where the attention comes from this is
where it goes to and
you can see that it kind of
decides that particular states are
important and it kind of remains at that
so
it selects a few states that
or a few tokens that it chooses to
attend
particularly to
in contrast to that our image gpt seems
to have a large recency bias so if you
see this right here
there's really this band right here
which essentially means that every token
attends to kind of the few tokens behind
it in order to predict it
then
well
the question is is it even worth looking
at stuff further down because this model
clearly doesn't learn at all so uh i i
would consider this and this just to be
kind of random random noise
the early layers might be interesting
though because there is kind of a
pattern and um
maybe that is influenced by the
pre-training so in image gpt since you
have your image and maybe it's in chunks
maybe it's in pixels but um
i can imagine that if i want to predict
a particular chunk that maybe the last
few that i've predicted unless i cross a
boundary right here and go one line down
the last few that i predicted are
or might be particularly worth looking
at and rather distant chunks might be
not worth looking at very much
other than in language modeling where i
often have to go a little bit more
across the distance and the exact
neighboring words might not be as
important so that might explain why
image gpt has this particular recency
bias pattern in its attention
what's also interesting is that the
randomly initialized model look at that
this is another interesting pattern and
you can see
that
very much the same as in the gpt example
happens except much more extreme so you
have these rows for example this row
right here you can see there is like a
hard attention to for three back like
there it's like really hard attention
then there are rows where uh you can see
right here there is always
no these two
right and then these two
and then these
two with particular attention on on the
first one and then also slight attention
on on the second one
and um
that's that's kind of
it's a special pattern so no i'm i'm one
off sorry in the the one above so this
is the hard the hard three then the one
below is the
i'm gonna call it the soft three so
there is one strong one and one weak one
and then the one even below that there
is like one semi-strong one week and one
really weak
so what's happening i'm not exactly um
so what i don't know here is which of
these tokens is returns
which ones is um
state and which one is action
but
i'm going to just guess and i might be
totally wrong right here that the very
strong
bias here that is going to be the
returns to go which would only focus on
the last returns to go
and then after that would be the state
tokens
so what the state tokens would do is and
you can see this i'm gonna i'm just
gonna
so let's say this is the returns to go
the right ones and you can see that in
the state tokens there is actually there
is one missing here on the diagonal so
this on this diagonal one here is just
completely blank which means that it
just kind of ignores the token um
behind it which is the reward right
so what it cares about is the last state
and it also cares about the last action
maybe
i don't i don't know how to interpret
that
that very much otherwise so if i want to
predict the next state i'm going to care
about the last state and the action
after that maybe that makes sense if i
want to predict the next action then i
might be able to care about all of the
about all of the stuff beforehand
a little bit
again i don't know if i'm interpreting
this correctly however what i am able to
say is that there is very very
structured attention right here um there
is this this pattern of three is very
prevalent and it is in general very very
structured
so
this
seems to be
actually the best kind of attention
right it is very structured in the way
it looks at the information it learns
exactly aha this there is a structure to
it i'm going to attend to the different
parts in this different structure
however
my hypothesis is and that is not super
duper discussed in the paper i mean it
is discussed but my hypothesis is that
this bias here it might be almost like
too strong like it might learn the exact
structure of this of this stuff but it
might be too strong and it might
information because it for example says
well i don't actually i don't need to
know
anything in between here because the
most relevant thing for predicting the
return
is the last return and therefore i'm not
even going to look at other stuff
whereas the language model pre-training
just kind of acts as a regularizer that
says well you should maybe look at
all of the stuff
even though you don't find it super
useful in this particular data now one
thing that i didn't point out in the
video that i wanted to point out right
now is that if you look at gpt2 at the
very left column what it does is it
focuses particularly on the returns to
go
steps it doesn't matter which step it is
at it always kind of looks back at the
very first token which is the returns to
go of the whole episode and among other
things also at like the second and the
third returned to go uh token and this
is important because the returns to go
is kind of an indicator of how the
episode's going to go along if the
returns to go are low it means that
entirely different episode paths should
be chosen in order to achieve that
reward whereas if the returns to go is
high then um i would i would do i have
to do different actions to get that
returns to go so it makes a lot of sense
to look at the returns to go tokens uh
and rather than where as you can see in
their right hand column the randomly
initialized thing it only really focuses
on the returns to go in in these middle
layers whenever it needs to predict like
the next return
and so it it's it's much more diffuse
and it doesn't condition all of what it
does uh a lot on these returns where it
makes total sense to do that because at
one in one instance the language
modeling is just sampling you know any
sort of high likelihood trajectory
however
in additionally in the gpt2 case it is
almost like conditioning that sampling
on the most relevant information that
distinguishes between the different
futures i hope that makes sense it makes
sense why a model that would learn to
focus in particular on this information
would be better at sampling appropriate
trajectories for the current episode all
right back to my comments in the past
we know that language models
retain large parts of their pre-training
even during fine tuning so
the
language modeling thing might just be
like a very good prior and i wonder if
we could build these types of priors
into the decision transformers
if we if we didn't do language model
pre-training but just as sort of like a
a bias or a regularizer or something
like this
um
yeah you can see that through the random
attention at the end you do not get this
focus as you get with the with the with
the language model thing that it focuses
on particularly interesting last states
but you'd rather you do get like an
attention matrix in the last layer that
is kind of diffuse um
and sort of similar to the image gpt
that just doesn't work at all
so yeah that would be that would be my
maybe postulation
that maybe it is possible to achieve the
same effect by introducing the correct
regularizers however i don't know
so they look at a few other things which
i just quickly want to go through
because they have pre-trained they can
demonstrate that their model
converges much more quickly so instead
of like three hours their models of the
same size needs 43 minutes and their
model that is a lot larger i believe
gpt2 is
144 times larger it uh
only uses uh an hour and 27 minutes so
still half of the time than this
decision transformer now i also wonder
whether they have based their code pace
on the decision transformer or whether
some of this difference is also due to
just kind of like a better
implementation
so
yeah that is
that is that they have some
analysis right here for example they say
they hypothesize that a generative
training objective is useful that's how
they explain why clip might not be as
effective because clip is a
a
ultimately a discriminative objective or
a contrastive objective
they also say that there are underlying
similarities between language modeling
and trajectory modeling where there is a
large difference between image modeling
and trajectory modeling which is it's a
hypothesis
um they they say yeah there is the
language modeling has a natural
sequential nature uh the
versus image modeling is kind of a
forced auto aggressive task i agree with
that but i'm not sure if
this is really due to like language
being particularly similar or whether as
i said it might just be a good prior
this would be an interesting question to
investigate
um and it might ultimately turn out to
be the same thing so you know
interestingly
the context size doesn't really matter
you can see right here if they increase
the context size they do get um worse
actually so we're yeah that's worse it's
just more noisy
which is special which
actually means that um these models
aren't
appropriate yet or we haven't really
figured out how to appropriately use
them yet right more information
shouldn't necessarily give you
less of a reward
unless i guess maybe you have a fixed
size data set and therefore you have
less
training data points
so maybe that's an effect of that
interestingly uh the pre-trained models
they do scale better
which i guess you might have expected if
you've been in deep learning the last
few years but if you just take a
decision transformer it will over fit
after a while if you if you scale it up
um so these are millions of parameters
uh you scale it up it actually gets
worse actually not sure if that's
overfitting or just you know it gets too
big and then
the average reward it decreases however
if you pre-train first um
then it can handle and it will actually
increase with more data interesting
would be to see if that at some point
actually declines again or if that sort
of holds up uh if the language model
pre-training for which there is like
infinite data right in language model
pre-training you can get infinite data
and therefore it could be that this just
kind of gets you diminishing returns but
not
ever
come down again
uh
yeah
they also they experiment with freezing
parameters
and they say that this
drastically reduces performance so if
they only train if they only train what
do they say
only action state and return projections
being trained so only this alignment of
this projection of the um
the projection
of the token embeddings are being
trained that doesn't work
much
which is also surprising because
there is a lot of work that kind of
shows that you you don't have to train
many parameters of these transformer
models to effectively transform or
transfer them from one task to the other
they say that this might be
this might be due to
the
task of generative modeling
being harder as opposed to
discriminative classification where this
was previously applied
they have a lot of yeah they
they pose a lot of hypotheses here of
why things might be and i feel each one
of them could be its own research paper
uh yeah i'm gonna leave it at that for
the paper explanation um
i hope you got a little bit an intuition
i still find it very very special and
very cool
that this even that this even works and
i think it's an
it's an uh
like a
sign of the times of our models just
becoming the same models for all
modalities this would not even have been
possible a few years ago where every
modality would uh would use very
different models like cnn for images and
uh rns for language and so on although
rnns were used for rl already
but
given that our models converge and
we're we're getting we're learning so
much more uh this type of research is
really cool
yeah let me know what you think
is have we overlooked something right
here like something that could easily
explain why this works and gives good
results that just no one kinda sees or
are there more applications for this let
us know what you think and bye bye